janet mais celui-ci grand secret la
marilyn castonguay vous êtes huguette la
calle de cinq fois dans la série c'est
comme ça que je t'aime première question
je m'adapte comment fait on pour avoir
l'oeil du tigre
fait ce sans arrêt chez le premier roi
est ce que c'est ce que vous avez fait
maintenant bel 10 ticks d'un concept
plainte et en même temps je pense que
c'était plus à l'image puis un effet de
deux caméras qu'on voulait une intensité
qu'on a mis ailleurs que moi-même bleus
je me fallait juste que je joue pis que
que j'ai dans la concentration de ce
mail à un autre et cette année à
développer le droit c'est et puis le
gauche et d'autres raisons
vous parlez de votre autre oeil parlons
justement de la deuxième saison comment
vous avez préparé votre personnage ben
tu écoute juste le corps c'est plus lui
même qu elle était enceinte puis sexy
c'est comme si je retrouvais un
personnage différent mais il fallait que
je retrouve quand même les repères
clé de ce personnage gothique dont le
petit que vous voulez les wisigoths la
mort mais en même temps je pense que je
pense qu'on aurait eu si justement à à
la mener même si et moins moins naïve à
l'amener où les gens au pouvoir quand
même s'attacher à égalité
vous maniez le fusil dans c'est comme ça
que je t'aime mais vous fait rire les
enfants depuis plusieurs années dans des
séries jeunesse je pense à 1 2 3 géant
ça lui bondi à l'excès les merveilleux
où trouvez-vous votre bonheur dans les
émissions pour enfants mais c'est une
liberté totale une série jeunesse j'ai
l'impression que tu crées une famille
pour n'avoir pas ce que ça revient tout
le temps de ses quotidiens puis à fait
arrivée au foot est comme chez vous
c'est dit c'est de l'imagination c'est
de la folie en même temps c'est quelque
chose de très sérieux affaire très
difficile et demandant aussi parce que
tu peux pas mentir aux enfants tu peux
pas comme un état parce que c'est que
c'est de l'énergie c'est quelque chose
de très vifs pitre et très freins comme
approche mais j'ai l'impression que si
tu es à moitié
sap ans - et bien un peu nous tu le vois
tout de suite en fait que c'était plus
ou moins bonne place et puis tu deviens
espèce de héros d'une génération puis
quand tu te vois dans les yeux des
enfants qui te reconnaissent
leurs regards d'admiration qui ont puis
le bonheur qu'ils ont hâte regarder ce
sera à peu près
retour en arrière vous avez complété des
études en danse au cégep avant de
devenir comédienne et d'aller à l'école
nationale de théâtre pourquoi ce
changement de carrière danse et ensuite
elle mais la danse eh oui c'était
vraiment mon grand rêve de danser puis
après semaine je te rends compte que on
a des limites tout si j'ai dit j'avais
des limites corporelles des maux de dos
qui ont fait en sorte qu'elle
entraînements étaient un peu plus
difficiles puis peut-être une petite
rigueur que j'ai perdu si le début
vérité notre monde cjp si j'avais pas
trop quel genre de danse puis quel style
aussi je voulais faire fait que j'ai
compris une pause puis je me sente
réunis ici à montréal mais c'est ce qui
m'a fait déménager à montréal en fait
mais j'avais toujours fait du théâtre
aussi puis cette rigueur là peut-être
d'entraînement que j'ai un peu perdu
puis que mon corps m'a empêché aussi
d'avoir en fait en sorte que j'ai écouté
une autre passion quitter le jeu puis
que ça a vraiment marché
depuis votre sortie de l'école nationale
de théâtre en 2010 vous avez relevé de
nombreux défis revault plus récents je
crois que c'est ce seul ou de près de
deux ans au théâtre intitulée les filles
et les garçons vous incarniez une mère
de deux enfants comment vous avez vécu
cette expérience mais au début j'avais
c'était très épars vraiment je pensais
pas être capable de de relever ce défi
lyautey est tout seul devant ces gens là
mais je t on on est beaucoup à le faire
aussi le touche pas unique je peux la
plus courageuse je pourrais la plus mais
mais c'est le thème abordé qui était
très très très sensible et délicat puis
c'est quelque chose c'est comme un
espèce de point tournant
d'avoir fait ce projet le mot amené
complètement ailleurs
et dans ma vision de et dans ma façon de
travailler est dans ma vision de voir
les choses qui à chaque soir tous ces
gens là qui ont été touchés par ce parce
par cette femme le à ce point là ça a
été pour moi la réussite marilyn
castonguay alias huguette je vous
souhaite de garder l'oeil du tigre merci
beaucoup c'est à toi le jute comprenait
une chose mon mari adoré je peux pas
m'occuper des tâches domestiques et en
plus diriger une organisation criminelle
enfin c'est un ou l'autre jusqu'à
maintenant c'est vous qui est rentrée le
week-end en raison également qui se mène
pas de ses affaires lui
j'en ai mis bout
[Musique]